so some of the big news yesterday was
that Donald Trump announced new federal
policy towards transgender service
members via no other platform than
Twitter saying that all transgender
people will be banned from serving in
the American military all branches in
all capacities Donald Trump just to
catch you up in case you missed it
yesterday announcing via Twitter that
quote after consultation with my
generals and military experts please be
advised the United States government
will not accept or allow transgender
individuals to serve in any capacity in
the US military our military must be
focused on decisive and overwhelming
victory and cannot be burdened with the
tremendous medical costs and disruption
that transgender in the military would
entail thank you at least politely
wrapping it up with a sign of thanks our
questions were did the Pentagon know
that this was coming number two did the
Pentagon agree with this policy were
Republicans in the House and Senate
consulted did they support this we have
now heard from the Republicans in the
House and Senate who were involved in
the discussion about this with Trump
they didn't want this they didn't ask
for this they wanted the Pentagon to
maybe not have to pay for the medical
costs associated with gender
confirmation period they didn't want an
outright ban or so they say anyway with
one exception at least congresswoman
Vicki Hartzler was involved with some
others in lobbying for an amendment on
the defense authorization bill to ban
the Pentagon from paying for what
congresswoman Hartzler was calling
transition surgeries as well as hormone
therapy and it appears that House
Republican leaders didn't even know that
the the outright ban of all transgender
servicemembers was even on the table
they thought oh we're having a
conversation about will taxpayer money
be used for medical treatments if so
should there be any other stipulations
or whatever the case may be Trump then
says hey you know what I'll just tweet
that all transgender people are banned
from the military and numerous people on
record saying that this call
by surprise now I mentioned
congresswoman Hartzler she actually
likes what Trump did she just wasn't
expecting it but she likes the fact that
Trump is had just no transgender people
in the military period other Republicans
don't like it this is a president who
said during the campaign endless times
he would be a friend of the LGBT
community he is now to the right of
House and Senate Republicans on an issue
of LGBT rights
that's how outrageous this declaration
from Donald Trump is yes either being
offensive this was just rolled out so
terribly I mean you're supposed to
inform you know Congress and they can
have hearings about this maybe in the
Armed Services committee's you're
supposed to tell the pawn Pentagon I
guess he was supposed to be in touch
with his generals then we find out that
general mattis was on vacation during
I'm not even around there there's some
delusion I mean it's a surreal
explanation of how somebody went to the
Pentagon asking for comment about this
and they basically said talk to the
White House about it and by the way Jim
mattis is on vacation anyway I pages
everything is a gong show there's no
rhyme or reason to anything that's going
on and obviously the next question is
are gays next in some way is there any
interest from Donald Trump either in an
appeal to his base or in an attempt to
distract from the endless scandals in
trying to reinstate something like Don't
Ask Don't Tell which we finally got rid
of in the military under President
Barack Obama or something is something
even worse and it's particularly notable
because we've had a number of people
saying listen nobody's really involved
in the whole fighting against gay rights
thing anymore even Republican Dave Rubin
in fact earlier you said yeah but you
know I'm a gay I'm a gay man and I'm I'm
I'm married but you know it's like
that's not even really an issue for me
politically because like it's settled in
the courts but yeah the marriage is
nothing I was there about yeah and then
literally the next day Donald Trump says
hey yeah transgender you're blocked from
the military and still for me the
biggest missing piece from this Pat
still no explanation as to what happens
to current members of the military who
are transgender I saw a retired general
on CNN yesterday say well you you would
probably dishonor or honorably discharge
these individuals fine how do you find
them
you find these individuals especially
when they may have already entered the
military as I presume most of them have
already with the gender identity that
they feel is appropriate for them are
you going to do a genitalia check and I
do want to issue one correction which is
yesterday I mentioned that transgender
individuals are less likely to be in the
military than the general population due
to self selection the data we have
suggests that that that's true in the
sense that we estimate 0.6 percent of
the population is transgender whereas
only 0.2% of the military population is
transgender but a few people email me
they said David actually transgender the
transgender community of members of the
transgender community are more likely to
serve in the military than the general
population so I may have misspoken about
that sure but it does seem like a
relatively small sample size so it's
hard to say for sure yeah this is this
is entirely insane I mean that the
reasons Trump cites is because you know
it would save money for the Pentagon's
budget almost cost five to eight million
dollars which is peanuts if you look at
the defense budget overall and I think
we calculated that it was something like
between 0.03 percent I mean it was just
some tiny fraction of the medical
military budget nevermind the total
budget and then the other thing is like
we need to decisively win wars which is
like what out how do twenty four hundred
and fifty as estimated by the RAND
Corporation transgender servicemembers
how is that going to impact our ability
to decisively win wars and by the way if
you're interested there is actually a
transgender member of the Navy who has
done sort of a de facto ask me anything
on the David Pakman show reddit
discussion forum I think you might have
seen a little bit about that more about
that later more about that later yes
indeed the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership